physical education class at seven in the
morning here in tiene ke bugu a village
that's a two-hour drive north of mali's
capital bamako
known to his friends as solo attends
what's called a speed school
he's completing an elementary school
education
it will take him just nine months to
catch up on three years of normal school
lessons incorporate elements of play but
discipline is also important
ten-year-old solo is one of 25 children
in the village who go to this school
he's ambitious and a hard worker
i know the alphabet
and i can count i can do a e a
o
o
n the first two months aren't easy
when the children first arrive they
can't write they don't even know how to
hold a pen
if it weren't for the speed school solo
wouldn't get any education at all
like many children here in mali he
didn't have an opportunity to attend
school when he was younger
solo isn't just learning to read and
write his confidence is also growing
plus he's learning to be punctual and
reliable
when school's finished for the day
i help out on the farm
i give the animals water every evening
and take them back to their stalls
i can only study when that's all done
staff from a local ngo visit families in
the region encouraging parents to send
their children to school
solo's parents realized it made sense
he didn't
prepares a candle so when night falls
solo can do his homework
one day he might follow in the footsteps
of foseini diarra
now 22 he's a student at the university
in bamako
fusani diyara is the only one in his
year to have received education at a
speed school
i'm studying education
lots of young people would like to go to
university but there's a shortage of
qualified teachers and lecturers in mali
i'd like to become a teacher and be a
role model for young people
the speed schools project has been
launched in a number of african
countries
allowing some ten thousand young people
like fosseni diarra to get an elementary
school education and prepare them for
secondary schools
in his free time fuseni diarra now
volunteers at village schools
today he's visiting solo's class he
hopes he can motivate and inspire them
he also came from a small village so he
understands the challenges they face
it's unbelievable to be here
it reminds me of the years i spent
studying in a hut like this looking at
my teacher at the blackboard and
admiring him
solo still has enough time to let off
steam and enjoy himself
today a football tournament is taking
place in the village
he scores the winning goal
success breeds success
solo hopes to match his performance on
the pitch with academic achievement